[Musique]
nous sommes aujourd'hui avec le proto
bus pour un atelier des changes en
mobilité avec l'usagé de paris saclay
pour leur parler des nouveaux lieux et
des nouveaux services qui arrivent sur
le territoire
le proto but c'est un peu plus d'un
nombre et donc il existe pour pouvoir
échanger que agit là où se trouve là où
le travail là où j'étudie effet
aujourd'hui là où ils mangent tout
simplement on y court vasseur qu'un
nouvel espace public proche d'un
restaurant interentreprises et d'un
crous plus généralement on est au
carrefour de quatre écoles finalement
l'école polytechnique lio js lénaïc et
rêver cette année et l'est mais télécom
qui arrive en 2019 aujourd'hui on est là
pour présenter donc une carte nous
aident card c'est comme un dépliant avec
deux faces d'un côté pour présenter les
mobilités les sentiers les pet
recyclable et bien sûr à une de bus et
de l'autre côté les nouveaux lieux
nouveau service soit existe qui vont
arriver sur les logements le sport les
loisirs la culture
et puis tout ce qui est une ovation
narnia
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on s'est mis en face du
combat soeur parce que les commerces ont
commencé à arriver à partir de la
rentrée de septembre à décembre 2010 8,7
l'après midi c'était le deuxième atelier
des changes avec les usages en mobilité
et on va recommencer à partir de la
rentrée 2010 8 pour continuer à être en
proximité à échanger à la fois sur
quatre et l'école polytechnique et puis
sur le quartier des moulins évidemment
[Musique]